le 19/20 continue voici le rappel des
titres les fidèles du régime six ou sept
coups devant leurs juges l'état roumain
poursuit l'apprentissage de la
démocratie notre invité dix new
hamsphire escou président de la ligue
des droits de l'homme en roumanie
l'opération de la dernière chance à
marseille une petite fille étant
d'urgence la greffe d'un poumon il ne
lui reste que quelques jours à vivre
le suicide de david au sens qu'il y ait
un générique qui dépensait sa fortune
dans les casinos pour compenser un trop
vide d'affection enfin nous parlons au
rugby avec les plus beaux essais de la
6e journée du championnat de france avec
aussi la réaction de denis charvet à
nouveau sélectionné dans quinze de
france met tout de suite un appel au
secours celui de mode une petite fille
de 7 ans atteinte de mucoviscidose et
qui luttent contre la mort depuis hier à
l'hôpital de marseille
il ne reste plus que deux jours aux
médecins deux jours seulement pour
trouver le poumon compatibles qui
permettra à la petite mode de vivre de
marseille daniel jamet elle s'appelle
mode croce et les corses et elle a 7 ans
elle a quitté depuis jeudi sa chambre et
sa maison de santa lucia di moriani pour
l'hôpital de la timone à marseille
là avec onze autres enfants elle attend
d'urgence l'organe qui lui rendra la vie
mode est atteinte de mucoviscidose cette
maladie héréditaire qui encombrent les
poumons au point d'empêcher le
fonctionnement d'enfants et quand elle a
effectivement très critique puisqu'elle
se trouve en ventilation mécanique qui
lie à une certaine détérioration de la
plupart de ses fonctions dans les jours
qui viennent si effectivement on
n'obtient pas les organes dans les
délais qui nous sont impartis pour
sauver moore d'installer depuis 48
heures dans le service de réanimation
pédiatrique il faut un poumon
un poumon d'enfants de même taille
qu'elle est d'un groupe sanguin
compatibles dès samedi matin la demande
en a été faite à france transplant une
structure nationale qui coordonne les
recherches d'organes
à l'heure qu'il est la recherche s'étend
à toute la france et à l'europe dans les
fêtes la terrible kate est celle d'un
enfant en état de mort cérébrale
accidenté peut-être et dont les parents
accepterait le prélèvement on ne
à ces personnes là ces donneurs
potentiels que ils peuvent dans leur
immense chagrin sauver une petite fille
aujourd'hui c'est la mienne demain ce
sera une honte d'être 48 heures peut
être plus des spécialistes c'est le
délai qu'il faudrait respecter pour
tirer mode des griffes de la maladie
meurtrière
c'est le défi que relève souvent sans
qu'on le sache les équipes de
transplantation déjà à deux pas de mode
à marseille un autre malade en sursis
atteint un coeur
il faut être bien clair cet appel
concernant la petite mode est destiné à
tous les médecins en france et à eux
seuls qui ont en charge des sujets en
état de mort cérébrale si par bonheur un
médecin nous écoute en ce moment et s'il
se trouve dans cette situation qu'il
appelle bien sûr d'urgence l'hôpital de
la timone à marseille
à l'étranger le gouvernement roumain
s'efforce de pratiquer le dialogue afin
d'apaiser les tensions tant avec les
étudiants qu'avec les partis politiques
de l'opposition dans le même temps
s'ouvre les premiers procès
spectaculaire de la pressée ou six coups
alors aujourd'hui c'est dans la ville de
sibiu diriger il ya trois semaines
encore par le fils du dictateur s'est
ouvert le premier procès de membres de
la securitate
ces derniers ne pourront pas faire appel
au jugement et je vous le rappelle
n'encourt puce est récent la peine de
mort
rémy goodrich et les les membres de la
securitate est mieux protégé par la
justice que leur chef suprême après le
jugement expéditif de nicolae ceausescu
et de sa femme elena c'est devant un
tribunal militaire qu'a débuté
aujourd'hui achieve ue le premier procès
d'agents présumés de lâcher koryta athée
seule information ce soir la
condamnation à 9 ans de prison d'un
commandant de la milice de la ville de
chimie bio pour le reste silence total
des médias roumains
tout juste at on appris que ni coucha
ocs coup le fils du dictateur ne faisait
pas partie de cette première série de
procès qui ne concernerait que quelques
personnes mais quelles que soient les
questions qui restent en suspens sur le
rôle réel de la securitate et lors de la
révolution
les roumains reste exigeant face à ceux
qui assument qu'en ce moment la
transition au pouvoir
hier pour la première fois depuis
quarante-huit les militants du parti
national paysans manifester librement
dans les rues de bucarest
cette opposition qui se reconstituent et
qui a enfin pu s'exprimer à la
télévision fera pression sur les
dirigeants actuels
pour qu'il reporte de quelques mois les
élections annoncées pour avril prochain
et puis les étudiants ont marqué à leur
façon ce grand dimanche démocratique
rassembler à l'institut polytechnique
ces jeunes roumains ont payé
suffisamment cher leur participation à
la révolution pour faire savoir qu'il
suivait de près le retour à la liberté
dans leur pays
pas de slogans anti gouvernementales
mais des critiques très vives sur leur
pseudo représentants aux conseils du
front du salut national critique doublé
d'un rejet catégorique de l'enseignement
actuel archaïque et orienter bpa tient
il ya 1 1000e ou le numéro un du teeu a
peut-être mieux et ce soir les risques
qui le rendrait à ne pas mettre en
conformité ses paroles et ses actes
pour créer la nouvelle société roumaine
l'invité du 19/20 ce soir dit nous à me
tirer ce coup vous êtes membre du bureau
de la ligue des droits de l'homme en
roumanie
cette cour spéciale pour juger ce que
l'on appelle les terroristes
il y a dans votre esprit violations
graves des droits de l'homme je ne pense
pas qu'ils aient à violer les violations
mais il faut voir comment s'est passée
super c'est d'ailleurs découlent
martial spéciales ont été créés
pratiquement dans toutes les
départements pour juger les soi disant
terroristes et peut-être aussi des
membres de la sécurité ou de la milice
qui ont tiré sur l'armée et sur la foule
sur les citoyens disent il faut voir ce
procès il n'y a pas eu pratiquement un
demi match secret défense c'est une part
de la révolution qui est confisquée au
peuple pour l'instant je pense qu' il ne
faut pas se dépêcher à condamner mais il
faut était quand même assez vigilant et
voir ce qui ce qui va se passer on est
très curieux de voir ces procès et il
cela des diables que des témoins enfin
des journalistes et même étrangers
puissent assister à ce genre de procès
mais a priori pour l'instant parlant
catherine ils n'ont pas pu assister je
voulais clore sur ce chapitre
oui alors vous parlez de vigilance
la semaine dernière les premières
manifestations d'étudiants ont eu lieu
le pouvoir tout d'abord quand et de
pouffer ces événements pour qu elle a
raison je pense que c'était un vieux
réflexe réflexe pourquoi pas ce que les
gens nous ne sont pas encore édité niño
un hôtel empêche d'ailleurs il il faut
être là pour voir à la télévision tout
le monde qui parle exactement la même
langue de bois en disant évidemment
autre chose mais avec pratiquement les
mêmes formules
langage telle était enfin
si vous avez confiance en ses hommes qui
sont au pouvoir je suis plus un peu
sceptique mais ce que je
je vous dévoile plus tôt c'est
l'apparition des vrais cons que pouvoir
parce qu'il faut quand même
j'ajoute il faut être vigilant il faut
être vigilant ne pas laisser les gens de
ce fonds qui dans leur peut-être
majorité sont des anciens communistes
certains qui ont tourné la veste assez
vite
quelquefois avec la vitesse de la
lumière surtout dans les fonds magie non
c'est à dire dans les entreprises et
dans les départements
je vous arrête sur les mots communiste
kounen employés l'opinion publique en
roumanie ne veut plus entendre parler du
comice pas du tout disons qu'on prononce
le mot communisme ou même socialiste
parce que ça c'est c'est pratiquement la
même chose pour les romains alors cesser
je sais c'est mieux de ne pas les
prononcer en roumanie
à l'heure actuelle merci pour ce
témoignage j'ajoute à propos de la
qualité elle est également une
manifestation massive pour la
réunification et contre la stasi à
l'epci environ 70 milles à 80000
personnes qui ont donc repris les
manifestations ce soir alexis qu en
afrique du sud l'espoir de la liberté
pour nelson mandela voici les
télégrammes de l'étranger préparer et
commenté ce soir par caroline signal
nelson mandela bientôt libérés ce ne
serait plus qu'une affaire de mois c'est
sa femme winnie qui le déclare à la
rendu visite à son mari aujourd'hui en
prison
elle en est ressortie avec le sourire
nelson mandela lui a demandé de préparer
sa libération
l'opposition est-allemande claque la
porte des négociations avec les cinq
partis du gouvernement
motif elle exigé un rapport sur la
dissolution de la stasi police politique
et ce avant 16h multina ultimatum lancé
au premier ministre hans modrow en route
vers la bourgogne mais celui ci a refusé
et présentera son rapport lundi prochain
révélation du président salvadorien
alfredo cristiani si l'armée a participé
au meurtre des six jésuites c'était le
16 novembre dernier
six personnes étaient sauvagement
assassinée à l'université de san
salvador
christiane il n'a pas révélé l'identité
de ces militaires qui ont été arrêtés
sociétés en france la mort d'un jeune
homme trop riche n'est pas assez aimée
david hauss en ski je n'hérite y
milliardaire s'est suicidé à nice et ce
onze mois après le suicide au même
endroit de sa compagne de 20 ans son
aîné
la seule qui m'a écouté affirmé ce jeune
homme pas comme les autres qui ces
derniers mois avaient trouvé refuge dans
le casino jean françois téaldi
c'est depuis cette coursive situé au 17e
étage de l'immeuble du calot marina de
villeneuve loubet que le jeune
milliardaire lyonnais david aux hans qui
s'est vraisemblablement suicidé dimanche
après une heure du matin une chute de 60
mètres qui ne lui a laissé aucune chance
avant de commettre son acte david
s'était rendu par deux fois au saint
barth un bar restaurant situé au
rez-de-chaussée de l'immeuble sur le
port de marina baie des anges depuis le
16 juin jour de ses 18 ans david avait
dilapidé une véritable petite fortune
dans les casinos de la côte d'azur et de
lyon 4 millions de francs laissés sur
les tapis les tables de roulette ou de
black jack
j'ai eu l'exemple de ma mère qui
flambait après le décès de mon père
avait il déclaré à la mi décembre alors
qu'il venait d'échapper à un braquage en
sortant du casino de lyon
david en voulait à sa mère qui disait-il
collectionner les amants à ses amis qui
l'accusé d'avoir volé tableau des tapis
persans de son père à son oncle qui
avait obtenu d'un juge d'instance une
mesure de sauvegarde lui interdisant de
disposer à sa guise de sa foi
une c'est le mandataire spécialement
désignés qui juge de l'opportunité de me
remettre ou non le courrier que je
reçois mes biens sont entièrement
séquestré et tout cela mais extrêmement
préjudiciable mais gare à la carrière
professionnelle que j'avais toujours
compte exercer qui est celle de
magistrats toutes ces turpitudes ont
sans doute été trop lourde à supporter
pour le jeune homme qui serait venu se
suicider à marina marina ou en février
depuis l'immeuble le bas rooney s'était
suicidé dans des circonstances analogues
2010 poète sert le professeur d'anglais
de 20 ans son aîné dont il était tombé
amoureux qui partageait sa vie si depuis
quelques mois
social 458 jours après la fermeture des
chantiers navals la ciotat relance ses
activités avec l'espoir que les accords
signés entre l'ex noir et la cgt
intéressant à terme près de 2000
salariés
lordon l'immédiat cet accord aboutit à l
embauche des 105 salariés qui occupaient
le site à site où régnait aujourd'hui
l'euphorie malgré l'incertitude qui
entoure encore l'éventuel reprise
d'activité à la ciotat de marseille
gabriel bruxelles depuis 458 jours ils
attendaient ce geste 458 jours depuis
lesquels ils espéraient entendre la
sirène des chantiers ce matin 7 heures
ils étaient 105 à franchir à nouveau les
grilles les 105 cégétiste qui depuis la
liquidation de la norme est d' occuper
le site eux n'ont jamais voulu
abandonner l'idée de la poursuite de la
construction navale lourde à la ciotat
l'accord qu'ils ont signé hier matin
l'ailier à la lexmark pour une durée
indéterminée
un accord signé dans la liesse générale
depuis le feu vert du conseil général le
22 décembre
ils attendaient cette signature pour
l'instant ils ne peuvent que remettre en
état le site l'outillage n'appartenant
toujours pas un alex marc il faut
continuer à se battre
pour le chantier naval il faut récupérer
l'outillage et il faut que la lex marc
auprès du conseil général signe l'acte
séparer lorsqu'elle aura rempli les
autres conditions
la suite c'est des cons a l'autorisation
on est des cons à l'outillage c'est à
dire ça peut se passer peut-être dans
aller dans un mois et demi dans un mois
et demi seront ils plus nombreux à
descendre les marches du vestiaire cet
avenir dépend encore de beaucoup de
conditions ce matin c'était surtout
l'instant à l'après quota surtout de
reprendre le travail
depuis avaient assisté 7h30
les 105 sont prêts à travailler les
équipes sont formées 458 jours après il
repart bien les ateliers en sport le
retour enfin des plus belles jambes du
rugby français dans le tournoi des cinq
nations denis charvet le trois quarts
centre toulousain mettra tout son talent
au service de l'équipe de france le 20
janvier prochain à cardiff
c'est contre cette même équipe qu'il
avait fêté sa première sélection
tout un symbole pour un joueur qui a été
mis à l'écart pendant deux longues
années un joueur heureux aujourd'hui
mais très prudent andré martre la
rencontrer coucou le revoilà il est de
retour denis charvet titulaire en équipe
de france avec les numéros 12 il ya bien
longtemps que cela ne s'était produit
associé à philippe sella denis sera du
voyage à cardy tous ses supporters
attendent beaucoup du stratège est
toulousain tout le monde se souvient du
coup d'éclat lors de la dernière finale
face à toulon pourquoi ne pas le
réitérer un terreau galloise de nous
charger atacora toute rencontre avec un
moral d'acier
le qualificatif de mal aimés étant
désormais banni de son vocabulaire
pourquoi j'étais un mal aimé non je me
suis jamais senti le mal aimé
c'est pour ça que j'ai toujours cru que
je pourrais revenir un jour en équipe de
france
vous savez que les britanniques disent
que philippe sella et denis charvet
c'est la meilleure paire de
de trois-quarts centre que l'équipe de
france puisse mettre sur un carré je ne
sais pas - ma joie est très grande parce
que je suis sélectionné aujourd'hui
maintenant la vérité c'est celle de
nivelles jambiers à cardiff à 3 heures
c'est pour ça que il est difficile
d'expliquer avec des mots ce qui se
passera dans nos quinze jours lagisquet
c'est la charvet blanco s'apprend mais
le 20 à cardiff rugby toujours une
chronique qui s'installe doucement au
coeur du 19/20 celle des plus beaux
essais et des faits les plus
significatifs du championnat
oui une sixième journée qui a vu la
première défaite de toulouse en revanche
grenoble reste invaincu et ont voté jean
philippe guillin grenoble toujours
invaincu malgré l'absence de nombreux
titulaires
les locaux ont véritablement enchanté
leur public en marquant sept essais ici
l'arrière vélo ira jusqu'au bout
chalon vince inclinés 41 à 6 grenoble
n'a pourtant aucun joueur titulaire en
équipe de france juste derrière grenoble
dax profite de deux erreurs de colomiers
pour s'imposer à l'extérieur 27 à 6 au
rugby les ballons mal négociés dans
l'en-but coûte très cher et ce ne sont
pas les trois quarts columérins qui
pourront affirmer le contraire
le dacquois dupuis lui ne se pose pas de
question et marc mal an xii toulouse 9
c'est en effet l'arrière sud africain de
tarbes qui a inscrit la totalité des
points de son équipe au cours d'un match
terne émaillé de quelques gestes
d'énervement
les champions de france nous trop
attendu avant de développer le jeu à la
main qui a fait leur réputation ils se
sont enferrés dans la défense tarbaise
réalisme puissance physique enchaînement
cadrage-débordement toulon malmené par
nice en début de match l'emportent
largement 34 à 10,8
les hommes des héros vont marquer cinq
essais eric melville français depuis le
31 décembre fait sa sélection
le troisième ligne aile en équipe de
france b en étant à la conclusion le feu
superbe mouvement bien soutenu par tous
ses coéquipiers
impressionnant ce paquet d'avants de
l'équipe de toulon est qu en sport
encore le classement du globe challenge
s'agit de voile bien sur les concurrents
de la course autour du monde en
solitaire et sans escale avec toujours
en tête
titouan lamazou abord il est en bas à
droite aborde écureuils d'aquitaine
il est à 13000 925 milles de l'arrivée
suivi de loïc peyron qui est à 3 168
milles de titouan lamazou jean luc
vanden aide 3e pierre follenfant avoir
de charente-maritime quatrième à 6 ans
717 milles du premier site sont lamazou
information de dernière minute dont je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure mais nous
venons de recevoir un instant les images
en provenance de leipzig en allemagne de
l'est je vous parlais de cette
manifestation comme tous les lundis
soirs qui a repris après une longue
interruption due au fait 70 à 80 mille
personnes qui défilent donc ce soir à
l'éthique brandissant des drapeaux noir
rouge or realm en criant des slogans en
majorité pour la réunification et les
manifestants scandaient également
décevant contre le sd le parti
communiste et la stasi ancien sécurité
d'état dissoute
on pouvait également entendre des
slogans de tonalité notamment
nationaliste rappelant les conceptions
du parti d'extrême-droite ouest allemand
et puis toujours à propos de l'allemagne
de l'est j'apprends à l'instant qu'à est
riche en équerre l'ancien chef de l'état
est-allemand a été hospitalisé ce soir
il souffre d'une tumeur rénale maligne
nova l'instant la météo complète de
florence klein les prochains
développements d'information ce soir sur
la soir 3 23h10 présenté par philippe
dessaint et nous retrouvons demain à 19
heures pour une nouvelle édition du 19
20 excellente soirée à tous bush